president biden has launched a new
government effort to fight global
warming
signing a series of executive orders one
of them blocks any new leases for oil
and gas drilling
on public lands his critics say that's
bad for business
and jobs ed o'keefe is at the white
house ed good morning
good morning michelle great to see you
remember what he took off as president
biden said the country is fighting
multiple crises the pandemic a sagging
economy
racial and political divisions and
climate change
as he tries to fight that issue there
are some critics concerned that the
changes he's trying to make
could further upset the economy in my
view we've already waited too long to
deal with this climate crisis
we can't wait any longer president biden
is planning to make the fight against
climate change a core part of u.s
foreign policy for the first time
he's also establishing a white house
office of domestic climate policy
and ordering the government to begin
buying zero emissions vehicles
this will mean one million new jobs in
the american automobile industry
the biden approach is a big change from
former president trump
who pulled the united states out of the
global paris climate accord
and rolled back more than 100
environmental regulations
arguing they slowed economic growth i
was elected
to represent the citizens of
pittsburgh not paris with an economy
already hit hard by covet 19 the
president said his plan
will create jobs when i think of climate
change
i think of the answers to it i think of
jobs mr biden is
also freezing permits to drill for oil
in offshore waters and
barring any new oil and gas leases on
federal lands
critics like todd staples of the texas
oil and gas association
say that decision will lead to big job
losses
not producing it here means it makes us
dependent on other
countries for this energy source because
there's a great deal of infrastructure
that is necessary
for renewable energies but newly
appointed u.s climate envoy john kerry
says the changes
will lead to economic benefits there are
countless economic analyses now that
show
that it is now cheaper to deal with the
crisis of climate
than it is to ignore it important to
note again that this executive order
only applies to new
drilling on federal lands also today
here at the white house the president
turning his attention to health care
policy signing an executive order that
will reopen
the healthcare.gov website beginning in
mid-february for about three months
it's designed to allow those that have
lost their jobs in healthcare during the
pandemic
to sign up for a government-backed plan
tony all right ed thank you very much